hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the Kerbal space
program okay anyway so we are here on
our eternal quest to get to the moon to
the moon we have failed before but we
will not fail again let me load up my
old spaceship II here this one it almost
got the stair if I didn't shoot us off
into space so we're gonna use this
design but we're gonna make some
modifications namely we're gonna put
more Rockets on this sumbitch it needs
more power needs more power to get into
the space area thing you know that thing
above the sky that we've been trying to
get to we need to get up véra Sh so what
we're gonna do we're gonna do is we're
gonna mount these a bit higher to try to
create the a bit more stability on this
and we're gonna have for instead a tree
I could do six but I feel like that
might just be a little overkill
cuz I'm trying to I'm not trying to kill
everyone I'm actually trying to succeed
is anything on there straight why does
that not look straight how it ever good
enough if it's not straight I don't know
everyone will die oh that's morbid but
anyway that's just how life goes okay so
what we need to do is slap those on
there and then make lots of structural
adjustments lots and lots and lots and
lots and lots of structural adjustments
OOP good enough that'll do it no more
needed you only need a few you only need
one that's what I say if it can't be
done with one well you should probably
do more all right boo boo because the
problem before that we were having is
that um as because it's so long and it
was pushing from the bottom it was like
wobbling as he was going up so I'm
hoping that having to thrust the center
of thrust um be a little bit higher like
just a little bit instead of down here
hopefully that'll create a bit more
stability I don't know I'm not an expert
at this
why are you looking at me don't watch
Scott manly he's the expert I'm just a
dick trying to crash
some guys on the moon that's all I'm
trying to do all right let some that
look good enough it saved that bad boy
no wait hang on we need to name it I
forgot about the name Oh
the crash team explores as that was it
that was the most famous project um the
the whammy he could blame me
ha ha ha ha ha the whammy could blame me
I love it let's go fry the maiden voyage
of the oh no I forgot the I forgot the
launch assists it's cut the crashed it's
got a crash my games gonna crash do oh
thank you I wonder if it'll stay on
there will it stay will it say will it
stand oh my god not good either get
other kerbals so dumb I'm so dumb I'm
just too dumb
why am I trusted with these things this
is me - dum - dum lefty there's
something missing hmm some needed for
the launchpad ah who cares get it out
there skit it at the door I don't even
care
ok so anyway get these in correct order
blah blah blah blah blah go pop them off
get a good we can now let's that's
enough thrust it'll get us there in no
time we'll be able to launch and release
at the same time because there's gonna
be just enough thrust because normally
you want to ignite the engine then
launch but with this much power on this
bad boy I think it'll be just fine
no no just some some some in the back of
my mind is saying this is gonna be fine
I don't know what though okay turn SAS
on very little wobble I like it pretty
steady
what do oh yeah right mouse button moves
it okay we got a nice is that morning or
dusk I can't even tell I don't care I
think this morning so you guys ready
Molony MIT done Baba where do I go
sweet all right now look at the power
there's much better than last one as you
can tell we're getting up to speed much
quicker and remember we want to throttle
down as you're launching because you
want to save as much power as possible
to bust through the top layers of the
atmosphere the bottom layers are really
going to slow you down with all of the
air resistance you need to keep it down
as much as possible so that you can have
the fuel left there that's why I've got
now that I've got four Rockets with more
thrust not only do I have more thrust
but I'll be able to save more fuel as I
go up and then I'll be able to do a
better atmospheric burn and I need to go
took this way down just keep it right
and even you're probably don't wanna you
don't want to do anything until you get
to 10,000 meters once you're at 10,000
meters then you need to change your
trajectory into your angular trajectory
so you can go into orbit and then then
you need to do a very controlled burn
and I'm going way too fast for this
level see see I've got I've got a good
bit of fuel here this will get me like
the in this art I'm gonna start my
maneuvers start my maneuvers but like I
said I'm not an expert I'm just taking
from what I saw so let's knock it right
there and then you guys ready for the
boom because right here you can get
massive amounts of acceleration now that
you're past the initial atmosphere and
you can use this to your advantage these
mainsails engines
they've got ridiculous amounts of power
okay let me start my next engine
throttle up and offload like a beaut
minimal roll so you can see we're doing
just fantastic as a matter of fact we're
doing so good I would bet I'm not quite
there yet we're but we're almost there
so let's bust it up we want to get to
about I don't know 12 thout 1,200 meters
per second I think is a good place to go
remember this is just the second stage
of our four stage rocket we've got well
I mean there's a lot of different saves
but as terms of Rockets go there's four
states why am I still spinning stop
spinning your douche
fix that fix your [ __ ] Oh your dot dot
don't be douche Dogma douche the Swedish
kerbals will not tolerate your douche
myths at the book yeah there we go
us so perfect okay we're above a hundred
thousand we can cut the engines now once
once you're on ape we're not above under
thousand are able stasis a poll abscess
a post APIs a poll abscess is about her
above a hundred thousand because once
you get above a hundred thousand that's
a pretty good launching point to correct
your orbit in order to get it and as you
can see our orbit is pretty much right
on the money with the orbit of the moon
X let's go ahead and set the moon as our
target bow what uh whoa what's going on
with my ship what the hell what's going
on with the moon
whoa hard what let's unset that as
target cuz that's that's obviously not
ready for orbit cuz we're not in orbit
yet we need to get into orbit okay
so we're still at a wonky level here but
since we're not thrusting we can go
ahead and correct to where we know we're
going to be thrusting which means that
we can maneuver our ship over to a more
angular almost almost 180 degrees
parallel to the earth angular Oh God
this is not meant for keyboards this
needs like a joystick or something
okay so right about there is where we're
gonna be burning and we're coming up on
it in just a minute but let's hurry that
up to five times up do you science is
fun
20 and kicking on hey J boogie 17 okay
here we go this is the important one
this is you one day meeting you most
Durga ten nine eight seven six five four
burn alright you can see once you're at
the April abscess of maximum coalition
ish you have a slight angular to the up
just off a center so that you maintain
your proximity to the April abscess and
that way you maintain that proper
connector II and you get
maximum expansion of your orbit waited
something imported wait what did that
exploit I'm jetting IDIA wasn't I was
talking you guys distracted me I wasn't
watching the overheating of my engine I
lost so much fuel do homage feel I did
wash wow you guys ruined everything I'm
trying to be scientific are you ruin
everything you Roy alright night ah
found me able to make Ohio enough to
make it do it alright I yeah but I
forgot uh I don't know if we're gonna
make it um hard to tell I don't know if
we can make it to the moon I mean we
might be able to get to the moon but as
far as nah now these poodle engines
won't do it gah turn it - dirty curse
turn it everybody it was going so well
no no but a professional you guys were
like I bet all of you were like he knows
so much wow he's so great and then you
were godlike up your engines your engine
- bro your engines bro ah ha ha his
engine exploded ah ha ha I'm mimicking
everyone in the comment section very
cool
I shake about fisting anger at you I
shake up a fish and Egger her her gir
grrrrrr all right whatever
what
I cut the engine don't cut him just go
down okay dear fika nice and easy
go nice and steadily huge kya you are
[ __ ] ah ah GABA you must girl we were
gonna make it to the mood
I mean we're gonna crash on the moon
anyway because we don't have any sort of
landing system but we're gonna make it
to the moon damn it you bear your back
it is Road gotta back it out are we
ready to the moon I don't even know
we're approaching tell us how the
Raiders verbal command we're proud to
cut down food meters what do we do well
you need to go in an orbital to the shop
command I know what best
I mean astral nurse okay getting into
orbit do boop doop well don't you be
spinning don't you be spending on me oh
oh
job jumping to hear me where are you
going try that come on I'll go bad move
move
where are you what why are you jump jump
jump ship through the god damn it you
stupid ship what are you doing
I'm Roy off you what happened oh look
Saturday's launch it boof Oh God
oh I got what the hell happened my I
suddenly lost control
I'm still losing control what is going
on I can't bring this thing back
what is the hell it just like drifting
it's like shooting off into the random
patterns I don't understand it it never
did that before
it just started randomly swinging okay
s8 now I turn SAS on and it's hard to
friggin spin
what the hell my ship it's like going
out of control I swear it's just has a
mind of its own
that's ass on okay good what the hell
was that
what the hell was that just get us into
orbit geez we're still kind of wonky but
whatever at least we're online all right
cut the engines where are we if your
step is we compromised our orbit like a
lie a lot cuz we're going to
horizontally and not enough up Italy we
need to burn up get up there's got to be
like turn SAS off go turn okay
there we go now cut the engines we
should be okay there we go
my goodness goodness wait I my word what
the hell happened yeah I don't even know
that didn't make any sense nothing that
says target I guess whatever no what was
that I don't even know I don't even want
to know I don't ever want to know I
don't know okay we're going I need I
need
RCS control oh man
because obviously I am not good enough
and our orbit is off kilter oh that's so
unfortunate okay that was like that what
you should not do in a crisis situation
is panic do not panic
come on get left stop twisting it's like
this is impossible to do with the
keyboard because you can't make my nude
adjustments it's all it's all like you
press it oh my god just get what are you
doing ship it's like oh my god get I'm
holding to the left and then I'm trying
to stabilize to the right it's like in
one direction it wants to go a lot and
then in the other direction it barely
wants to move at all okay here we go
goat I'm heading up to go down go down
stop stop DUP I've already missed the a
post ASA so I got to burn more up [ __ ]
it there we go
we're going everybody hold on to your
britches we're going into space we're
going into fight don't ask me how we're
gonna watch our heating this time [ __ ]
what the hell
Oh ever know I ever now alright whatever
okay crisis averted we're about to get
into orbit okay there's our we just ran
out of fuel I wasted so much fuel just
going like this all over the place wacky
waving inflatable arm-flailing tube-man
get your wacky waving inflatable
arm-flailing tube-man here at your wacky
waving inflatable arm I always hold you
a spaceship oh yeah
okay whatever we're in orbit that's all
that matters we're off kilter so we're
gonna have to burn perpendicular to the
planet in order to go away so what needs
to happen is as soon as this gets over
here hurry the hell up
I've screwed this this engine is not
very powerful but then again this ship
is not very big what we need to do is we
need to basically if our ship is going
along the line in orbit we need to point
um let's see point down and that'll burn
our trajectory slightly downward and
that way when we orbit like if we're
orbiting we're orbiting and kind of on
to the axis of the years we're orbiting
in a sort of off axis orbit like this if
you burn down you'll slowly like orbit
down because it's not falling because
it's not with respect to gravity it's
with respect to your axis of the earth
so by thrusting down you're not
degrading the the performance of your
orbit you are instead just shifting the
position in respect to the earth see you
get it get it that didn't make any sense
at all you did it ha ha I'm not good at
explaining things but basically what I
got to do is I got to figure out um see
which way is up and which way is down
I'm thinking I only sees if I'm pointed
in that is
kind of up and that is down so I need to
point that way no that way
your you guys Jamia was correct but to
you guys I need to point that way
okay Harry I guess um he's not gonna go
well no no the way wait hang on I need
to go that way
Yes No maybe so I'm not sure I don't
know I'm no expert at this I am anything
but an expert just hold there stop
spinning please thank you it's like the
SAS does not do well with spin okay
whatever
so I think oh god if this isn't correct
up good I bid a lot of trouble okay
let's see are you shifting down oh my
god it's actually working
haha kinda maybe maybe kinda I don't
know oh god no no what's going wrong
it's going wrong it's going wrong oh no
I needed to go 180 degrees I went 90
degrees ah mother oh god I can't do
anything right yeah there's the other
node that's the uh never mind I've meant
I I went 90 degrees instead of 180
that's why it was kind of going right
but not quite gosh it's no bad at this
I'm not I'm not I'm not okay
this it probably isn't even gonna work
anymore because it's effed it up so
badly let's see come on come on
nope this is not working this is not
working I am doing something horribly
wrong
oh good I am stuck I lost my orbit how
did I lose cuz I'm burning retrograde I
needed to burn up or down wait up doing
it laterally oh no what I'm doing
we're crashing into the earth screw it
I've gone I've got Arctic crazy we're
going straight into the earth everybody
good no okay
let's just calm down we got this I got
to get back up to the A+ stasis and then
I got a burn oh my god I'm so bad at
this
oh I'm so bad at this oh oh he's so bad
I'm so bad all right whatever I see us
off get over to that node get over to
that note I wouldn't even have enough
power to get back into the earth I don't
think I just have to wait until my orbit
slowly this sins oh come on stop moving
I ain't Adama there we go urn [ __ ]
boots I'm totally turned in the wrong
direction so I don't know what's gonna
happen to my angle of orbit but it's
gonna go wrong alright what we're gonna
do is either screw it we're gonna just
keep pumping on this one until our hippo
stasis grows all the way to the moon and
the moon is not gonna be there obviously
but we're gonna be there someday don't
know when but someday we're gonna be
there you and me everybody you and me
we're gonna be there and we're gonna do
it and we're gonna win maybe cuz our
angle is still wrong but we should be
able to get close enough to still get
captured by the moon's gravity which
means that we will be able to once we
get over there to be able to get where
we need to go and then we'll be good
right everybody right right yes
everybody have faith in markiplier I am
your great leader fearless leader on
this expedition of terror all my other
kerbals are like huh hold on I can't
control what's good ah
and they're all grabbing the sticks
while they're trying to correct things
while I'm doing random stuff and they're
like yeah
can't keep it under control some
mysterious voice is controlling us from
above
alright whatever you and uh kata to
Endor schnikeys
I went a little too far okay zoomy
forward miss not too fast forward just
go a little forward okay now we go zoom
me forward now we go super zoom me for
it cuz we're moving missed our target
okay are we going to hit it again up no
no let's see purp what of fun Jewish boy
that's not what I gave her out in the
world where am I going
I did it again I got a gun wait a bit
I'll boo some I might loop back around I
hit it again
I don't know god damn it it always
happens and all I got was not fair
it not fair I would I gotta come back
around for a second shot oh yeah oh god
I'm sorry
ah out of terrible games of terrible
games I'm gonna visit this turd but I'll
get it next time
I'll look at my other spacecraft that's
orbiting the Sun whoops oh my god that
was actually now it actually probably
could go to Dunas oh man hope the guys
in there just like the greatest ever as
they're getting older and older and
running out of food and they're like
this is still fun yeah same with these
guys except eventually they're gonna
coincidence with kerbin again and then
crash into the planet or get launched
into space one or the other I don't know
which but I have royally boned up every
attempt to get to the moon by somehow
well I know how but somehow really
boning everything up okay
patience is key in this game be patient
don't get too happy with the L
accelerating time cuz it's like an
incremental scale this is this is ten
thousand this is a hundred thousand it's
a lot different so don't do what I did
don't launch your kerbals into orbit
around the Sun if I wanted to go to Allu
I guess I could get close God whatever
anyway well I have a successful if I
wanted to create a space station around
the Sun I am well on my way so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will
you in the next video by
Oh
but